what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today we will be
talking about the most recent
developments in the story of black
clover including the secret behind the
Hart kingdoms unique magic and how
exactly some members of the Hart kingdom
are able to access far more mana than
anyone in the clover kingdom we've
definitely learned a ton of new useful
information and this will have a major
impact on the rest of the story and
definitely on this current arc so I had
to break it all down for you right here
in this video before we get started I
want to give a quick shout out to the
one and only mr. beast and his new
hashtag team trees initiative mr. beast
and his team reached out to a bunch of
us youtubers to ask us to support a
really worthy cause and what's the cause
we are going to plant 20 million new
trees by January 1st 2020 mr. beast has
set up a website team trees org where
every donation of $1 will go to planting
one tree on this wonderful planet we
call earth oh what's that you don't care
about trees trees are not sexy enough
for your weeb tastes well it's not like
they give us oxygen or anything baka but
fine here you go we got tree Chan and
sakura-chan two beautiful tree wife
who's created by our good friend Johnny
let's talk anime so head over to team
trees org link in the description and
joined the team trees cause if not for
the oxygen then do it for the lovely
tree wife who's one tree equals one
waifu also definitely check out Johnny
let's talk anime he's a hard-working
artist on anime fan and a supporter of
the channel and O our rant cafe anime
podcast finally this video will contain
black clover manga spoilers we're
dealing with the latest developments in
the black Laura story so please proceed
with caution
you have been warned chapter 2 to 6 of
the manga begins with Gaia using a
powerful form of lightning magic but
this magic is different from the type of
lightning magic that can be found in the
clover kingdom this is evident from the
rune like symbols that appear around
Gaia as he uses his magic despite the
immense speed of lightning magic Noel is
able to dodge using
her Valkyrie dress however Gaia has the
ability to command his magic to simply
chase its mark until it reaches the
intended target
mimosa wonders whether this is a special
rune Manship technique that is unique to
the Hart kingdom mimosa and FINRA also
get involved in order to help Noel
mimosa tries to be reasonable and she
asks Gaea nicely to give back hasta so
they don't have to keep fighting but not
surprisingly Gaea refuses instead Gaea
sends his runes up into the sky and they
form an alchemical circle up in the sky
above him Gaea then proclaims that
humans cannot hope to match the vast
amounts of mana found in nature as
ominous dark clouds begin to form around
Gaia's alchemical circle I think that
this statement from Gaia is very
important as it seems to suggest that
the secret of the hard kingdom's power
and the secret of their magic is being
able to channel the power of nature into
their spells the power of the Hart
kingdoms magic users does not depend
just on the mana of the user himself or
herself but rather the user is able to
tap into the vast amounts of mana found
in nature in order to make his or her
own spell far more powerful than it
would have been otherwise this
revelation makes perfect sense based on
what we know so far about the Hart
kingdom the Hart kingdom is covered in
luscious nature and the human
settlements are embedded in this nature
and coexist in harmony with this nature
we also know that the Queen apparently
has enough mana to hide the entire
kingdom in fog which seemed insane when
we first heard about it and asked on
Noel and the gang were shocked to learn
that any one person could have damaged
mana it all makes a lot more sense if we
consider the following
perhaps the Queen does not actually have
so much mana on her own instead it's
likely that the Queen is just able to
tap into the vast natural mana of the
Hart kingdom and this is what allows her
to hide the entire kingdom and perform
other insanely powerful long-range
spells the queen isn't just using her
own mana for her spells she is
channeling the mana of nature the rivers
the forests the air and so on the
ability to do this makes the Queen far
more power
fold them she would have been if she had
to rely just on her own individual mana
our perspective then switches to the
other fight that is taking place at the
same time which is the fight between the
queen of the hard Kingdom and hasta the
queen is attacking hasta with a large
number of armored Knights generated from
water magic and hasta is using his anti
magic to hold his own against them
suddenly a voice calls out to hasta and
this voice is able to accurately
identify right away that hasta is able
to negate magic and that this is the
power of his demon the voice then
introduces herself as Undine
the pact bearer of the queen of the
heart kingdom and one of the four great
elemental spirits so of course she is
the water spirit because she was able to
identify the nature of Asta's power so
quickly Undine uses her immense water
magic to drag hasta sword around
essentially forcing him to go in
whichever direction she chooses and no I
am sure that we will definitely not get
any jokes in the comments about the
Queen pulling us the sword we're way too
mature and sophisticated for that here
at Anime uproar but aside from the Queen
jerking us around with his sword it is
important to stop and talk about how
quickly Ondine was able to recognize the
nature of Asta's powers and the fact
that this was the ability of his demon
it is cleared it on Dean and by
extension the Queen are very familiar
with demon magic and perhaps they
already did research on Aastha before he
even arrived inside the heart kingdom
after all someone who lives in a world
surrounded by mana is not likely to be
familiar with the idea of anti magic it
is after all an extremely rare ability
that shocks and puzzles most of the
people who come across it so the fact
that on Dean and the Queen figured out
so quickly what was going on
tells me that they have extensively
researched demon magic and perhaps even
hasta himself on Dean also notices that
hasta has no magical abilities within
him and she calls him a tier 9 hasta has
no idea what this means since the clover
kingdom does not have a tier system so
on Dean explains that this is a ranking
system based on magical ability and
prowess tier 9 is the lowest and
therefore weakest here and then it goes
up all the way to zero which is the
highest and therefore strongest tier
Undine then proceeds to chain hasta down
with water magic in a way that the
chains are not touching off the sword
so hasta is unable to effectively break
the chains
since the Queen seems to be totally cool
with watching Austin drown it looks like
she really does intend to kill him and
not just steal his grimoire we will have
to wait and see whether she is
definitely evil or just ruthlessly
pragmatic but from what we've seen so
far she seems to be very comfortable
with putting someone she barely knows
and someone who did nothing wrong to her
in life-threatening situations back at
the battle between guy and the other
three guests from the clover Kingdom guy
is using his unique magic to basically
summon incredibly strong flashes of
lightning from the sky but Finn Ramos
and Noel had wisely decided to dodge the
attack using spatial magic this was
definitely a smart idea because it looks
like Gaia's attack was insanely powerful
he left a crater in the ground and you
definitely would not want to be facing
the brunt of that attack back at the
battle with the Queen sacré makes her
appearance she suddenly transforms into
her human form and she uses her sealing
magic to unseal AUSA's chains and
release asta before he drowns for some
reason Undine is surprised to see this
type of magic meanwhile Gaia is
impressed that Finn Ramos and Noelle
were able to use teamwork to teleport
away from his attack and far enough away
from him not to be able to sense them
and then they are able to teleport right
behind him in time for Noel to hit him
with her infamous sea dragons roar in
terms of the Hart kingdoms tier system
Gaia has revealed that Noelle's magic is
Tier one and mimosa's magic is tier
three and thanks to Ondine we also know
that hasta is of course tier nine while
fighting on Dean and the Queen hasta
realizes that he needs to conserve his
anti magic he can't keep using anti
magic freely at full power because this
allows Ondine to bait his anti magic
with her own magic and this lets her
drag hasta around in the water until he
runs out of air Aastha then notices that
the Queen the user of the water spirit
Ondine is located in an area that is
sealed off from the rest of the room
with water magic meaning that the area
in which the Queen is standing must have
err hasta storms passed on Dean and her
magic and head straight for the Queen
herself and that is how the chapter ends
with hasta trying to make his way to the
Queen as Undine looks surprised at
austin's newly
formed strategy I believe that this
chapter just low-key answered a lot of
our questions about the heart Kingdom
and its seemingly insanely overpowered
queen the thing that makes heart Kingdom
magic so unique is the ability of its
magic users to tap into the mana of
nature and what allows the Queen of
Hearts to have such a massive mana zone
is again her ability to use and channel
the mana of nature such as the mana of
the ocean the trees the rivers and so on
this makes a lot more sense than the
idea that one person has so much mana on
their own one question which was not
answered in this chapter was the
question of why the Queen of Hearts
seems so desperate to gain Asta's demon
power if we look at how she has been
governing the Hart kingdom and how she
has been living in harmony with nature
it doesn't make sense that she would
want asked us power just because she is
greedy and power-hungry
assuming that maybe she wants asked us
power in order to defend herself and her
kingdom from an even greater threat then
we have to ask ourselves what could
possibly pose enough of a threat to make
her think that gaining asked as demon
power is the only way for her to fight
back
with how powerful this Queen appears to
be and with how powerful Hart Kingdom
magic appears to be it seems crazy to
think that she would become so desperate
for more power unless there was a really
good reason and the only potential
reason that I can think of right now is
the demon Meggie Kula perhaps the Spade
Kingdom along with the demon Meggie Kula
have been expanding into the heart
Kingdom and the Queen needs demon magic
in order to fight fire with fire but at
this point I'd love to hear what you
guys think is tapping into the vast
amount of nature the real secret weapon
of the Hart kingdom and why do you think
that the Queen is so intent on taking us
does demon power let me know down in the
comments if you enjoyed this video and
you want to see more please leave a like
to let me know and if you have it to be
new to anime uproar don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications feel free
to hit me up on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar and of course don't forget
to support mister beasts awesome
initiative just visit team trees dot org
and see how you can help I want to give
a big thank you to all of our anime out
pro patrons who make videos like this
one possible special thank you to all of
our pro here
to your patrons including the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason
Wilson Kings ell dress on he'll cruise
Steelers poet Pablo
atropos Wraith fitted alibied a karate
GN Anatoly Cassatt's ki TJ Nathaniel and
alpha do and I can't forget the ones
that rise above all other clans a
massive thank you to all of our the one
tier patrons including in grata alone
Adam madam AK makoto-kun and your boys
Seth if you enjoy our videos and you
think that they add some value to your
life consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
cowboys
[Music]